(background chatter)
- (thinking) Oh.
Janine just liked one of
my photos on Instagram.
That's weird.
I've never even talked to Janine.
Like why would she like one of my photos?
She doesn't seem like a person
that will like just
any photo on Instagram.
What's this mean?
Does she like me?
Oh my God.
That's it.
She hit the heart.
She gave me her heart.
It's so obvious now.
How could I have been so blind.
The signs.
Liking my photo and ...
Well, just liking my photo.
If that's your quirky way
of asking me out, yes.
I will go out with you.
Will I be your boyfriend?
Duh.
Is that too upfront?
Well, you were upfront enough
to profess your love to me on Instagram.
No ones ever made me feel the way
you make me feel right now.
Food tastes better.
Flowers smell better.
I don't have a care in the world.
What color should my wedding tux be?
(intense music)
Did you just like Zack's photo?
Wait, what's going on here?
Are you cheating on me?
(crying)
Okay.
We can work through this.
We're gonna have twins.
We're gonna be so happy.
No wait, no.
How could you?
Zack?
Why Zack?
He was gonna be the
best man at our wedding.
(yelling) Fuck you, Janine!
We're done.
We're through!
Why?
- Oh, Janine just liked
my photo on Instagram.
Eh.
(upbeat music)